Um, los españoles tenemos la sensación,
bueno, la sensación cierta,
de que al final del día coalición Canaria
está contribuyendo a sostener a Sánchez.
¿Eso es así? Entonces mi pregunta viene,
¿por qué hacen esto? ¿Les encanta como gobierna?
¿O hay 1 pago muy fuerte que hace a Canarias?
Y si es lo segundo,
tendría la gentileza de concretarnos
y decirle a todos los españoles
que les está dando Sánchez
para que lo estén apoyando.
Vamos a ver Cristina,
eh Cristina valido,
ni el colisión Canaria
ni mi voto están sosteniendo al gobierno.
Como ustedes saben, es la única manera,
ha ocurrido esta semana, ¿pero
eh? Habitualmente es que están con 179.
Son otros los que están sosteniendo al al gobierno.
Bueno, usted vota a su favor,
no voto a favor de lo que he acordado
con este gobierno que iba a gobernar
con nosotros o sin nosotros,
en 1 escenario en el que Canarias no se podía
permitir el lujo de no negociar,
de no acordar,
de no conseguir los recursos que necesita,
estando por debajo de la 2ª del estado, a 2 000km
y con enormes problemas